so how do we find the zeros of a
polynomial using a graphing calculator
as well as synthetic division that's
what we're going to talk about in this
video so the first thing that you want
to do is you want to go to your
calculator graphing calculator go to y
equals and you want to input that
polynomial in for y1 so then what we're
going to do is we're going to go over
here to graph and you can see that it's
crossing the x-axis at 1 as well as at 2
so let's just make a note of that 1 & 2
are what are called zeros of our
polynomial meaning when x equals 1 y
equals 0 when x equals 2 y equals 0 but
you can see this is a fourth degree
polynomial which means that there's
going to be 4 zeros but you can see that
two of them are going to be imaginary
because it's not crossing the x-axis for
x it's only crossing at two points how
do we find all of the zeros well we know
that one and two our zeros let's go
ahead and do some synthetic divisions so
if one is a zero now let's put the
coefficients of our polynomial here one
negative three six negative twelve eight
you can see there's no missing term so
we don't need to put a zero for a
placeholder we bring down that first
term and we multiply on the diagonal one
times one is one
add straight down that's negative two
multiplying the diagonal add straight
down multiply on the diagonal add
straight down multiply on the diagonal
add straight down now you can see you're
getting zero here which tells us that 1
is a zero and what we can do now we also
know that 2 is 0 let's go ahead and do
some thank Division with two so we can
do is we can again bring down that first
term multiply on the diagonal add
straight down multiply on the diagonal
add straight down multiply on the
diagonal add straight down now you see
how we're getting a 0 again so we know
that 2 is a zero and we started with X
to the fourth every time we do this
synthetic division goes down by one
degree so it's X cubed now it's x
squared so what we have here is 1x
squared plus 0x plus 4 and if we set
that equal to zero we can find the
remaining zero so I'm going to subtract
four from both sides and that's x
squared equals negative four
I can take the square root of both sides
remember when you do that you get two
answers plus or minus square root of 4
is 2 square root of the negative 1 gives
us the I so these are our remaining two
zeros now if the middle term wasn't zero
like it was here you could still do the
quadratic formula once you get it down
to a quadratic you would just do
negative B plus or minus square root of
b squared minus 4ac all divided by 2a
and go ahead and put your a B and C in
this case a is going to be 1 and C is
going to be 4 B is going to be 0 since
we didn't have that that middle term